bonjour avec sandra bien j'aurais eu sur
le plateau de télématin on vous laisse
la parole jour julia bonjour madame
chers téléspectateurs
à beugin
spectateurs bonjour
j'ai toujours rêvé de
2,10 recettes
[Musique]
vous aimez quand je suis serein
travaillé pendant je n'aime pas alors en
fait regarder j'écris agathe va au
marché mais non et ça fait super bien
est ce qu'en fait je suis comme ça avec
un air bravant très concentré et puis
après j'ai un petit mouvement de cheveux
et je trouve que ça passe très très bien
wes mes patrons me regarde il disait de
gaulle c'est tout chaque minute compte
pour préparer cette élection bonjour
chers téléspectateurs mais j'ai toujours
rêvé de de dire faites cette phrase
j'ai un problème
dont je vous ai tellement bien la
comédie
paul pogba at-il vraiment solliciter un
marabout pour jeter un sort à kia mbappé
l'international français dément lors de
sa seconde audition devant les
enquêteurs paul pogba invoque une autre
raison selon nos confrères de france
info il assure avoir versé de l'argent
aux marabouts pour une association
humanitaire qui aide les enfants
d'afrique aussi il assure avoir les
preuves pour étayer ses propos
[Musique]
à
là tout le monde qui peut se prendre une
balle c'est horrible il faut que je me
place derrière les groupes de gens comme
ça ils vont me protéger moi je prends
avec protéger les gens là ici c'est
chacun pour sa mère et dieu pour tous
paul pogba est aussi revenu sur le rôle
de son frère aîné mathias il disait
l'avoir reconnu parmi les malfaiteurs
qui lui réclame 13 millions d'euros
selon la star des bleus mathias
n'agirait pas de son plein gré mais sous
la pression des racketteurs pourtant son
frère lui a tout de même envoyé un
message sans équivoque lors de son
transfert de manchester united à la
juventus turin cet été tu penseras à
nous maintenant que tu as reçu une prime
à la signature et la polémique débute
sur twitter avec cette vidéo sur ces
images prises par marco garatti lors du
déplacement des joueurs parisiens à
nantes marquinhos et neymar semble
détendue dans l'avion ce qui n'a pas
manqué de faire réagir le patron des tgv
de la sncf paris nantes est en moins de
deux heures en tgv au psg je re re
renouvelle notre proposition d'offre au
tgv adapté à vos besoins spécifiques
pour nos intérêts communs sécurité
rapidité service éco mobilité
excusez moi je me doutais qu'on allait
avoir cette question là
pour être très honnête avec vous ce
matin on a parlé avec
la société qui organise le déplacement
d'un train de voir si on ne peut pas se
déplacer en char à voile
[Musique]
descamps 4
terry
aux couleurs de la sem
les oiseaux à
bonne nouvelle le concept de sobriété
énergétique commence à être intégré sur
france 24 par exemple ils sont déjà au
taquet sur les économies preuve que le
retour vers le futur ça prend du temps
et c'est la fondation cole reddition
5pourquoi merci ont tôt fait de l'avoir
suivi l'actualité continue sur notre
antenne rester avec nous voilà ça c'est
l'exemple à suivre un départ de
mélenchon en suv de la marque jeep sous
l'oeil des caméras tout le monde lui est
tombé dessus sur les réseaux sociaux
faut dire que ce n'est pas le modèle des
voitures qui incarne plus la sobriété
énergétique surtout après avoir dit sa
demande est pourri par le saccage de
l'environnement un bad buzz pour jean
luc mélenchon qui a vivement fait réagir
sur les réseaux sociaux après avoir
rappelé aux gens l'importance de
l'écologie dans son discours de lille
jean luc mélenchon repas dans son 4 4
fais comme je dis mais ne fais pas comme
je roule mais sur twitter certains de
ses soutiens ont tenté de le sortir de
ce bad buzz jean luc mélenchon n'a pas
de voiture c'est une location par
ailleurs c'est une hybride elle a
transporté 5 personnes et le matériel
moins polluant qu'un prestataire avec
camions mais chez une maîtresse je te
l'avais pas dit
que l'on a trop parfait pl troyes
s'est pas encore fait celui-là j'ai
documents ged notamment jane
c'est dame nature quand elle m'appelle
je cours je vais
bon si ce n'est que ça
[Musique]